>> DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA ARE
TAKING AIM AT REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR RON TO SANTOS AS HE
SENDS MIGRANTS TO THE LEFT'S
FRONT DOOR.
>> Reporter: WHAT THESE
GOVERNORS HAVE DONE IS TO
TRAFFIC THESE FAMILIES.
IT IS CRUEL AND SICK AND
SADISTIC.
>> THIS IS STRAIGHT OUT OF THE
AUTHORITARIAN PLAYBOOK.
THIS IS SO DISTURBING ABOUT TO
SANTOS, TO USE HUMAN BEINGS TO
WEAPON EYES HUMAN BEINGS FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES.
>> POLITICAL, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF MIGRANTS WHO ARE ALREADY
SUFFERING.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR YOU
PERSONALLY?
>> SOME POLITICIANS WOULD
RATHER NOT ONLY HAVE AN ISSUE
BUT EXACERBATE IT TO THE EXTENT
OF LITERALLY HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
>> HERE TO REACT IS FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JOE CONCHA.
THOSE CLIPS ARE SO FASCINATING
TO ME BECAUSE OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WITH OUR TAX DOLLARS
DOES THE LAST LEG OF THE REAL
HUMAN TRAFFICKING BY THE EVIL
CARTELS, BRING THEM ACROSS THE
BORDER AND THEY KNOW THAT OUR
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO PUT THEM
ON A FLIGHT OR BUS SOMEWHERE.
>> THAT IS THE THING, THAT CNN
SEGMENT WHERE THEY COMPARED
SENDING MIGRANTS TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD TO THE HOLOCAUST, TALK
ABOUT HYPERBOLIC.
IT IS NICE.
I HAD A SALAD AND DIET COKE
THERE ONE TIME.
FOR $200 COMPARED TO A SECOND
MORTGAGE, THE BIAS OF OMISSION
STANDS OUT BECAUSE WHEN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FOR MONTHS
AND MONTHS WAS FLYING HUNDREDS
OF FLIGHTS, JACKSONVILLE,
FLORIDA, WESTCHESTER, NEW YORK,
GOD KNOWS WHERE ELSE, THAT
WASN'T CONSIDERED KIDNAPPING OR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING BUT NOW IT IS
BECAUSE OF THE GUY BEHIND IT,
RHONDA SANTOS WHO THEY SAY IS A
TRUE THREAT IN 2,024.
HERE'S THE STORY AND YOU KNOW
THIS BECAUSE YOU'VE COVERED
THIS, 750 PEOPLE HAVE DIED
TRYING TO CROSS THE US SOUTHERN
BORDER THIS YEAR ACCORDING TO
DHS, IF YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE HEALTH AND WELL-BEING OF
MIGRANTS COMING TO THIS COUNTRY
MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS A LOT
BETTER THAN BEING AT THE BOTTOM
OF THE RIO GRANDE.
>> IT IS THE DEADLIEST CROSSING
BY THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> 4 MILLION PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO CROSS IN THE TIME THIS
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN IN OFFICE,
TAKE THE POPULATION OF
WASHINGTON AND MULTIPLY IT BY
6, THAT'S HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE
COME INTO THIS COUNTRY AND WE
CAN'T HAVE ANY REPORTERS THAT
ARE WILLING TO COVER THE TRUE
STORY BUT THEY ARE ALL GOING TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD AND HURRY.
>> BUT THERE'S NOTHING TO COVER
BECAUSE THEY GOT RID OF THEIR
MIGRANTS.
THE ELITES ON THAT ISLAND DID
NOT WANT THOSE PEOPLE THERE FOR
VERY LONG SO WE WILL MOVE TO
ANOTHER THING, I WILL PLAY THIS
CLIP OF PRESIDENT BIDEN WHO
FINALLY COMES OUT OF THE
BASEMENT IN THE WHITE HOUSE TO
GIVE AN INTERVIEW AND IT IS ON
60 MINUTES.
HERE'S WHAT THEY HAD TO ASK
HIM.
>> YOU HAVE JUST AVERTED A
NATIONWIDE RAILROAD STRIKE THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN CRIPPLING TO
THE ECONOMY.
HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
AND WHAT WERE THOSE LAST HOURS
LIKE?
IN THE NEGOTIATIONS?
>> President Biden: WE BROUGHT
BUSINESS AND LABOR TOGETHER.
THE ALTERNATIVE WAS
UNTHINKABLE.
IF IN FACT THEY HAD GONE ON
STRIKE THE SUPPLY CHAIN TO IN
THIS COUNTRY WOULD HAVE COME TO
A SCREECHING HALT AND WE WOULD
HAVE SEEN A REAL ECONOMIC
CRISIS.
RACHEL: THE COUNTRY IS FALLING
APART LITERALLY, FALLING APART
AND THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
SERIOUS INTERVIEW WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN, THAT IS THE
QUESTION YOU ASKED?
>> THE PRESIDENT HASN'T DONE AN
INTERVIEW ON TELEVISION IN 219
DAYS AND THE VERY DAY THIS
CRISIS WAS AVERTED PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAPPENS TO BE SITTING
ACROSS FROM SCOTT KELLY, 60
MINUTES, AMAZING TIMING AND
THAT IS IF IT WAS A FIXED
FIGHT.
RACHEL: TELL ME WHAT THE LAST
HOURS WERE LIKE.
IT IS SO OVER-THE-TOP.
>> HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
I WOULD ASK THE PRESIDENT WHY
HAVEN'T YOU VISITED THE
SOUTHERN BORDER?
IS THAT GOING TO BE ASKED?
WE WILL FACT CHECK HIM ON THE
FACT THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID
WE ARE HAD 0 INFLATION WHEN IT
WAS 8.
5%, WE ARE GOING TO FACT CHECK
HIM THAT HE SAID COSTS ARE
COMING DOWN FOR FOLKS AT THE
KITCHEN TABLE AND THE CPI INDEX
SAYING IT IS UP 12%, I WANT TO
SEE MY FATHER'S 60 MINUTES, THE
MIKE WALLACE 60 MINUTES AND
THIS PRESIDENT PRESSED ON
EVERYTHING FROM INFLATION TO
CRIME TO THE BORDER TO
EDUCATION AND EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT IS WRONG WITH THIS COUNTRY
AS A PR STUNT.
RACHEL: WE ARE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME.
WHAT DOES IT TELL YOU THAT THIS
IS THE CLIP THEY USED TO
ADVERTISE THE INTERVIEW COMING
UP?
>> THIS IS OBVIOUSLY DESIGNED
TO PROP UP THIS PRESIDENT AHEAD
OF THE MIDTERM SAYS THE HERO
THAT CAME IN TO SAVE THE DAY OF
A CRISIS, A RAILROAD CRISIS NO
ONE WAS TALKING ABOUT FOUR DAYS
AG